[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: My
name is Maya Kaczorowski.
I'm a product manager
here at Google.
I focus on encryption at rest
encryption key management.
And that's what we'll
be talking about today.
So I'm a crypto nerd,
but you might not all be,
so I'll cover some primitives,
as well, before jumping in.
We'll talk about how we
encrypt data at rest at Google,
the options that you
have as a developer,
and some partners that
you can work with in order
to have more options.
I also apologize, I'm
kind of losing my voice,
so you can decide at
the end if this was
more painful for you or for me.
So first let's talk about what
kinds of encryption we have,
in general.
So you can think
about encryption
in three different states--
encryption at rest,
encryption in transit,
or encryption in use.
Encryption at rest
is what you use
to protect your data
from exfiltration,
in case your device
is stolen, et cetera--
it's how it's protected
at the base layer,
on hardware, on a device.
This is the focus of the
talk that we'll have today.
The second point,
encryption in transit,
is how we protect data when it's
moving between two locations.
So how we first authenticate
the endpoints, encrypt the data,
validate that transaction,
and decrypt that data
once it's been moved around.
So Google uses RSA 2048-bit
certificates to our front end.
We use perfect forward secrecy.
We were the first major provider
to use perfect forward secrecy
on our cloud.
And all of that's,
again, by default.
You don't have to configure
any of that for your data
in transit.
The last point here,
data encryption in use,
is how you can protect
your data while it's
being used by a server.
This is a newer concept
in the crypto community.
And you can think of something
like homomorphic encryption,
which you might have heard of,
as being a topic in this space.
It's something
that's much newer.
It's not as practically
applicable yet.
Google does to
research in this space,
but it's way beyond
the scope of this talk,
so we're not going to
talk about that today.
So let's talk about
how you might be doing
encryption right now
if you're a company.
So if you're a smaller
company, a startup,
if you have something
on-prem, you
might not be encrypting
your data at all,
or you might be relying
on your cloud provider
to protect your data.
So you're kind of like this
Service A situation here--
I have some data, it's there,
I don't know if it's encrypted
or not.
I don't have the
infrastructure to manage that.
If you're a larger
enterprise company,
you probably have
some way of encrypting
your data and managing keys.
If you're in your
own data center,
you actually might not be
encrypting your data at rest
in your own data center.
But you might also be
more sophisticated,
and have a custom cryptographic
library, and a central Key
Management Service, or a KMS.
So that's what you
see in Service B here.
So I have some data
in my application,
and that data is
encrypted with a key.
Because it's centrally in
a Key Management Service.
If you're a much more
sophisticated enterprise
company, you probably have a
more complex key hierarchy.
So we'll get into what
that means in a second.
But you're not just using
one key to protect data,
you're using multiple
layers of keys.
And that's because when
you start encrypting things
at really large scale, it
becomes really hard to manage
a massive amount of keys.
You might also be
using something
like a Hardware Security
Module, or an HSM,
to protect your data.
So in application C
over here, Service C,
you have some data that's
encrypted with a key,
and that key's encrypted
with another key,
a key-encryption key, that could
sit in that Hardware Security
Module.
So it's a more
complex key hierarchy.
So what do we offer at Google?
So you have a
continuum of options
before, if you're doing
things on-prem right now,
in terms of maturity.
The same idea at Google.
Depending on where you
lie on this spectrum,
you're going to pick
a different thing.
And it's not about
picking an option that's
specific for your company, it's
about picking option that's
specific for your workload.
So the first option, and how we
do default Google encryption.
Google encrypts customer content
stored at rest by default,
with no action required
from the customer,
using one or more
encryption mechanisms.
And I'll be talking about
this more in a second.
We're the only cloud
that does this.
You don't have to go check a
box to turn on encryption--
it's just there.
This is no-op security.
For most of your workloads,
that's probably good enough.
The second one--
customer-managed
encryption keys in Cloud KMS.
So Urs mentioned
yesterday morning
that Cloud KMS is in
general availability.
I'm super excited.
What Cloud KMS lets you do
is generate encryption keys,
use them, rotate
them, destroy them.
They're AES-256 symmetric keys.
And you can use them
right now if you're
doing application layer
encryption, secret management,
et cetera, et cetera.
If you have a requirement to
manage your own encryption
keys, that's the option for you.
The last option here is
customer-supplied encryption
keys, where Google does
this a bit differently
than our competitors.
You can provide
us with some bits
that we use to
protect your data.
I'll talk a bit more what
I mean by that in a second.
But we don't actually
write those bits to disk.
We only keep them in memory.
So we're not
recording what you've
given us anywhere at Google.
We're the only cloud that
has this exact set up,
and that's pretty exciting.
So this is already available
for data objects in Google Cloud
Storage, and for disk instances
and images in Compute Engine.
And we have new
partner integrations
that I'll be
talking about today.
If you have a requirement to
manage your keys on-premise,
use multiple parties
to manage your keys,
or a requirement to generate
your own key material,
then that's the option for you.
So recapping, you have
an array of options here.
If you don't have any
specific requirements,
don't worry about it.
You can walk out right now
and your data is encrypted,
it's great.
If you have a requirement
to manage your own keys,
Cloud KMS.
If you have a requirement
to generate your own keys,
keep your keys on-prem,
or keep your keys
on a secondary provider,
then C-SEK is the way to go.
So I'll be delving into
what each of these offer.
So first, default
Google encryption.
How does Google encrypt
everything at scale?
Because it's massive.
So to understand how we do
that, you have to understand
how we store data at Google.
When an object is
uploaded, for example
to Google Cloud
Storage, we shard
or chunk that object
into smaller pieces.
And then each of those chunks
gets a locally-generated data
encryption key, or a DEK.
That key is generated on that
machine that writes that thing.
I'm talking about storage
layer encryption here.
Each chunk will have a
unique data encryption key,
even if it's part of the
same Google Cloud Storage
object as another chunk,
even if it belongs
to the same customer
as another chunk,
even if it's sitting on the
same machine as another chunk.
We have a super small,
low-level isolation--
cryptographical isolation--
for how data is stored.
Access to those
chunks is controlled
through access control
lists at a per-chunk level.
So the storage
system controls who
can actually access those chunks
and those keys at that level.
Those chunks are distributed
across Google's infrastructure
for latency, backup,
storage, et cetera.
And we also actually
backup data encrypted.
We don't decrypt it
and re-encrypt it
in the new backup system.
We just take it and
move it somewhere else,
and it's backed up that way.
So if someone were to try to
walk into Google and steal--
steal hardware, steal something
physical-- and take your data,
they would first have to
know where all the chunks are
that their object
has been split into,
which is a really non-trivial
problem at Google's scale,
have access to all those chunks,
and have access to all the keys
that encrypt those chunks.
So where are those keys stored?
Well actually, you
can think of them
as being stored as, like, a
header to that data chunk.
But of course, we're not
going to write data encryption
keys in plain text--
no, no, no.
We're going to encrypt
those data encryption keys.
So we encrypt them with another
key called the key encryption
key.
This is the hierarchy that
I was mentioning earlier.
So we have data encrypted
by data encryption keys,
and data encryption keys
encrypted by key encryption
keys.
Those key encryption keys sit
inside Google's internal Key
Management Service, or KMS, and
KMS was built for that purpose.
So KMS does not allow
keys to be exported.
Rather, the data
encryption keys go
to KMS to be encrypted and
re-encrypted, and sent back.
That allows us to
have auditability
over how those key
encryption keys are used.
That also allows us to
have those tight ACLs
that we want, again, on how the
usage of those key encryption
keys by services
and users is done.
KMS is highly scalable,
and it has to be,
again, to operate
things at Google scale.
So it's incredibly low latency,
high availability, and globally
available.
And what that actually
means, in practice,
is that our KMS runs
on tens of thousands
of production machines in
Google data centers globally.
So when you actually are
pinging something and getting
a piece of data back, there
is an encryption process
happening.
And it's hitting a
local instance of KMS
in order to decrypt that
data and get it back to you.
That's what allows us to have
encryption at scale at Google.
All right, so you guys
are like, OK, I got--
you know, I'm skimming a slide.
So first, how does
that work in practice?
So you can think
about this as being
three different actors here.
There's a service
that's using the data.
There is a storage system that's
storing the encrypted data.
And there's a KMS that's
storing the encryption keys--
the key encryption keys.
So what happens in
practice is the service
asks the storage
system for some object.
The storage system verifies
that the service has the right
to access that object,
figures out all the chunks
in which that data is
stored, checks those ACLs.
Then it pulls the
data encryption keys
that are sitting with
those chunks of data,
and passes those data encryption
keys, encrypted, to the KMS.
The KMS then verifies
that the storage system--
again, another ACL
check-- that it
has the right to access
those key encryption keys,
decrypts those data
encryption keys in memory,
sends them back to
the storage system.
And people often ask me--
that connection here between
the storages and the KMS,
that's an encrypted RPC.
So you're not sending around
plaintext keys on our network.
Then from the storage
system back to the service,
the storage system
decrypts the data,
and sends back the plaintext
data to the service,
in most cases.
In some cases, the service
decrypts it directly.
Again, that's a general example.
For something like SSDs, it's
actually a locally-managed key
for the SSD at the DEK level.
But this, in general, is how
storage works in our systems--
sorry, encryption and
storage work in our systems.
So you're like, OK, we
got data, data encryption
keys, key encryption keys--
it's turtles all the way down,
right?
Kind of.
So what happens next?
This is the fun part.
So we said earlier, we have
some blue-- data, the yellow--
data encryption key,
green-- key encryption key.
And that key encryption key
is stored inside our KMS.
All right, but we're not going
to write keys to disk, right?
We said that earlier.
That's not going to happen,
plain text keys to disk.
So when KMS is not
running in memory,
where are those keys stored?
Well of course, they're
stored encrypted on disk.
So they are wrapped
with a KMS master key.
And that KMS master
key sits in another KMS
that we call root KMS.
And root KMS is much smaller,
has maybe a dozen keys
that are really critical
to Google's infrastructure,
and runs in special security
machines in our data centers.
Root KMS is, of course, itself
protected with something
called the root KMS master key.
So the root KMS master key is
held in distributed memory,
in a peer-to-peer infrastructure
that we'll call the root KMS
master key distributor.
That's the fun part about
taking internal code names
and trying to explain
them externally--
I end up with root KMS
master key distributor.
So the root KMS master key
distributor is kept in memory,
and basically what happens is
a new job spins up and says,
I'm the root KMS master
key distributor, give me
the root KMS master key.
And it has a list of
all the other hosts
that are running the root
KMS master key distributor.
Asks it for the master key, and
they pass it back and forth,
and you have another
instance up and running.
I think it's explained in much
better detail in our security
design white paper.
But the reason this
can work in practice
is that every job that
spins up at Google
has a unique identity.
And so when something spins
up and asks for the root KMS
master key distributor, we
know that that's actually
what it is-- it's not
faking and potentially
another rogue piece
of code or something.
So what that means
in practice is
that your data is stored
locally to wherever it is,
with the data encryption keys.
The key encryption keys are
stored on prod machines in KMS.
Root KMS is run on security
machines in our data centers.
And as long as at least one
instance of the root KMS master
key distributor is running in
memory globally, in theory,
we're fine, right?
OK, now what if everything
at Google goes down?
What if every single
Google data center
loses power simultaneously?
We have nothing running
in memory anymore.
I love working at Google.
People think about
problems like this.
What that means in
practice is that we've
written that key to disk,
to security hardware kept
in physical safes, in at least
two globally-distributed Google
locations that less than
20 people have access to.
And so if everything at Google
were to completely go down,
someone would go open a safe,
get our root KMS master key,
put it back into production
as we turn back up our data
centers.
Your data will still be there,
and it will still be encrypted.
So that's how--
that's kind of cool.
So again, a quick
summary-- that's
many, many layers of
the key hierarchy there.
But we can do this in order
to encrypt your data at scale
at Google, by default. The sexy
line that you get to say is,
"Google Cloud Platform
encrypts customer content
stored at rest,
without any action
required from the customer,
using one or more encryption
mechanisms.
#GoogleNext17" So there's a
white paper on our website that
explains this in detail.
All the same
diagrams and things.
Everything I'm saying
right now is public.
And there are a few
exceptions around logs
and that type of thing,
but those are all
explained in the white paper.
We're not hiding anything here.
So that's what you
get by default.
And once you explain this to
your CSO, and they're like,
no, no, no, I still need
to manage my own keys.
You're like, great.
Google has this other
thing, called Cloud KMS.
Cloud KMS is now in
general availability.
It lets you generate, use,
rotate, and destroy keys,
and has a couple features that I
want to just highlight quickly.
One is automatic rotation.
What that means in
practice is that we
can generate a new crypto
version for you, that you
can use to encrypt data
on an automatic basis.
So you can say, for example,
as a rule, every 60 days I want
a new crypto version created.
And we don't re-encrypt
the old data, but we--
you can therefore limit
the amount of data
encrypted with any single key.
The second item here
is a 24-hour delay
for key destruction.
So I'm very terrified about a
customer potentially destroying
an encryption key without
realizing that it encrypts
data, and therefore,
losing access to that data,
for all intents and purposes.
So we built in a
purposeful 24-hour delay,
so that when you
say, destroy key,
it goes into a kind of a
temporary suspended state
for 24-hours, and you
can restore that key--
again, to prevent
error, insiders,
any kind of other risk
that could happen there.
IAM and logging were integrated
with cloud IAM, have predefined
roles to allow for
separation of duties,
that I'll talk about in
a second, and logging.
We're integrated with
cloud autologging.
Cloud autologging has
two kinds of logs.
Admin activity logs--
which are on by default--
which are things like
change IAM permission,
change key rotation
policy, et cetera.
And it has data access logs--
which are not on by default,
but you can turn on--
that will say things like,
was this key used to encrypt?
Lastly, KMS is available via
our gcloud CLI, client libraries
in seven languages, including
Go, Java, Python, and then
through the cloud console UI.
I do often get a
question, so I'll just
point out really quickly--
just like our KMS
internally, keys in cloud KMS
are not exportable.
So somebody will
be like, hey, how
come I can't see my encryption
key on the cloud console?
That's by design.
You can't see the
encryption key.
The only way for you to interact
with that encryption key
is to send data via an API.
You'll get back encrypted
or decrypted data,
depending on the request
that you were making.
Let's talk about a couple
of concepts in Cloud KMS,
so that we're all
on the same page.
Object hierarchy-- so Cloud KMS
has the concept of CryptoKeys.
CryptoKeys are objects
that sit inside KeyRings.
KeyRings are just
groups of CryptoKeys.
CryptoKeys are like
a named object that
has a set of CryptoKeyVersions.
The CryptoKeyVersions are the
actual cryptographic material.
So when you're talking
about a new Version,
we're talking about a new
set of cryptographic material
that we're going to use to
encrypt or decrypt data.
The CryptoKey
itself has nothing,
and no particular material
[? is hid to it. ?]
Key states-- CryptoKeyVersions
can be in multiple states.
They're listed here--
enabled, disabled, scheduled
for rotation, destroyed.
Enabled CryptoKeyVersions can
be used to encrypt and decrypt
data.
Disabled Versions means that
they cannot be used to encrypt
and decrypt data.
So far, so good.
There's another
important concept
to grok here, which is that
of a primary key version.
A primary version is
the version that's
used to encrypt your data.
So now that we
understand that, when
we were talking about
key rotation earlier,
rotating a key--
what we actually do is
generate a new version
and make that the
primary version.
So we're not talking about
re-encrypting old data,
but we're limiting
anything else that you
want to encrypt with that key.
Scheduled for destruction
and destroyed--
what happens in practice, when
I was talking about destruction
earlier, is that when you
say, destroy this key,
we move it into the state
scheduled for destruction,
and then after 24 hours
it becomes destroyed.
If it's still in
scheduled for destruction,
you can restore it, and
get back to something
like enabled or disabled.
In terms of key
rotation, I already
explained what I meant by having
a new CryptoKeyVersion created
and making that primary.
You can do that
automatically, so like I said,
set a policy-- every
30 days, every two
days, whenever you want-- and
create a new CryptoKeyVersion.
And you can also do that
manually, via an API call,
or on the UI.
And lastly,
separation of duties.
I mentioned that we have some
predefined roles for IAM.
What that means
in practice is you
might want to have an
organizational control that
says, the people who use
the encryption keys aren't
the same people who manage
the encryption keys.
So we set that up
for you already.
We have two roles.
You can give Alice the
cloudkms.admin role
and Bob the cloudkms.cryptoK
eyEncrypterDecrypter role.
And that means that
Alice can manage
who has access to the keys,
and rotations, all of that,
and Bob can set up something to
encrypt data using those keys.
What happens in practice is that
Bob will probably be a service,
so you'll probably want to
give something like a service
account that role.
We also have encrypt-only
roles and decrypt-only roles,
if that's something
that you're looking for.
What makes Cloud KMS special?
Things that your SRE
is going to love--
scalability, global
availability, and latency.
Scalability-- you can have as
many KeyVersions as you want.
So I had a customer
[? who wanted me to-- ?]
they're like, can I
have 1,000 key versions?
I'm like, of course--
do you want a million?
You want 10 million?
Just hit us.
The reasoning behind
this is that we shouldn't
have to limit how you can
encrypt data at scale, just
because you can't have as
many versions as you want.
You should have as many
versions as you want.
This also enables a
use case which I'll
call cryptographic isolation.
You might have the
desire for your data,
that each of your
customers' data
is encrypted with
a different key.
But every row in a
table that corresponds
to a particular customer is
encrypted with a separate key.
That's possible with Cloud KMS.
You can implement that,
there's nothing stopping you.
So go forth and encrypt.
The second one here,
global availability--
Cloud KMS is a regional service.
So what that means
in practice is
that you pick a region in
which to create your resources,
CryptoKeys and KeyRings.
CryptoKeys and KeyRings
can't be moved, or renamed,
or actually, in Cloud
KMSes case, deleted.
You can destroy all the crypto
materials associated to them,
but you can't actually
delete that resource.
And that's for logging,
auditing, historical purposes.
So something like
global availability--
you can create a key
in, like, us-east-1,
but you can still
access it in Europe.
There's nothing stopping you
from using that key globally.
So you don't have to have a
different key in each region.
We have optimized the keys
in those regions for latency,
but that's not preventing
you from using it elsewhere.
And last one here-- latency.
Cloud KMS is very fast in
encrypt and decrypt operations,
on the order of tens
of milliseconds.
So you should be able to
use it in the serving path
of your application.
You shouldn't
non-encrypt something
because you're worried about
your application starting up.
So this should not
be a limit again.
Again, all things your
SREs are going to love.
And part of that is also
with our general availability
announcement.
We posted an SLA yesterday
morning around availability,
around uptime.
So you can see that
on our website,
and that comes as part
of standard Cloud KMS.
OK, I'll take up some water.
So we've been talking
about secret management--
sorry, encryption keys.
What did I do?
Yes, please-- please help
me with my notes, please.
We've been talking about
encryption at rest encryption.
So one of the first
uses Cloud KMS
might be encryption at
scale-- bulk data encryption.
So you might want to implement
something like a multiple-key
hierarchy-- like I just
described that Google does--
to encrypt your data.
That lets you have
encryption at scale.
A second use case is
around secret management.
So you might have some
small pieces of data
that you want to keep
secret in your application.
One such example
would be something
like API keys, OAuth tokens,
some super-special credentials
that you have,
something like that.
And typically, developers
that I've talked to now
are keeping those in
a variety of places.
But they include things
like directly in the code,
in the metadata of a VM,
in a deployment manager,
in a configuration file, in
a bunch of different places.
And that's all fine, and--
I think we have multiple
slides happening.
OK, cool.
We'll figure it out.
Cool.
So you can store secrets in a
variety of places right now.
What we're also going
to be publishing today--
publishing yesterday--
on our website
is a set of questions for you to
think about secret management,
and an option for how you
could implement that at GCP
with what's currently available.
So what I mean by that is that
there's a variety of questions
you might be having
around secret management.
You probably want to
optimize for a few things
around security
and functionality.
Strong security-- something
like authorization,
like, who should actually
have access to the secret?
How do I manage
access to that secret?
Version management--
how do I know
that all my applications
have the same version
of the secret right now, and
that they're all in sync?
Encryption-- are my
secrets encrypted at rest?
These types of questions.
I'm not going to click anything.
Give me one second.
So what we're hosting
on our website today
is not a be-all and end-all.
You can think-- there's
probably a couple of ways
you can improve on just
hard coding secrets in code.
The first one would be just
to encrypt those things
that are hard coded in code,
so that they are more protected
than if any of your
developers could have access,
but some of your
developers have access.
A secondary improvement
could be something
like putting all of your
secrets in a bucket,
and encrypted that bucket--
like a Google Cloud
Storage Bucket--
and putting the
right IAM, the right
logging information,
all that, all around it.
Another option might be to use
a third-party secret management
solution And I
think, again, this
is another array of
options and complexity,
like, what are you
looking for out of this?
If you're just looking to
limit a little bit more access,
you're looking for
additional auditability,
or you're looking for more smart
features, like secret rotation,
you might pick
something more complex.
So what we published is
a bit more explanation
as to how we do it, with Cloud
Storage Bucket, Cloud KMS, IAM,
and cloud autologging.
It's not the best solution.
It's not the best solution for
your environment, necessarily.
But it's one way you can
think about managing secrets
in a central way, securely.
Awesome, thank you.
The last option that I
talked about earlier--
so we had default
encryption, we had Cloud KMS,
and we had customer-supplied
encryption keys.
And customer-supplied
encryption keys--
so what happens here in
practice is that you provide us
with a 256-bit string.
We assume it's probably
an AES-256 key.
We combine that with a
random cryptographic nonce--
so that the
randomness of that is
sure to be at least
within level--
and keep that in memory, and
use that to encrypt your data.
So we talked earlier
about data encryption keys
and key encryption keys.
What this means in practice
is, for data objects in GCS,
images, instances,
and VMs in GCE,
we can use what you provided us
plus that cryptographic nonce
as the key encryption key.
The more complex thing
here is that you might not
have a really easy way of
managing those keys locally,
because we need you to pass
us that key as part of an API
call.
Since we don't store that
key on disk, only in memory,
and only for the amount of time
required for that transaction,
every time that you would
need to access that object,
or write that object, or spin
up that instance, or whatever,
you need to re-provide us
that key in that API call.
So what we're announcing
today is a couple
of partner integrations
to make that significantly
easier for you.
Yes.
So if you're looking to use
customer-supplied encryption
keys, you basically need
to have a KMS on premise.
We have a variety of
partners who are going
to help us do this for you.
For customers without
existing KMS solutions,
you can look to work with them.
So using KeyNexus products--
KeyNexus Enterprise On-Prem,
and KeyNexus Cloud--
you can provision a key
both for GCE via gcloud,
or for GCS via gsutil.
Using Thales nShield HSMs--
which are FIPS 140-2 level
3 compliant-- so if that's
a requirement that you have
around FIPS compliance,
you can supply a key
for use with GCE.
Using Virtru, you can supply a
Virtru generated a key for use
with GCE.
Using Ionic's products--
Ionic Protect for
cloud storage--
you can supply a key
for use with GCS.
And using Gemalto's products--
SafeNet KeySecure-- a
product, again, a key for GCS.
So KeyNexus right now is
supporting GCE and GCS;
Thales and Virtru, GCE;
and Ionic and Gemalto, GCS.
And we're going to expand
that in the future,
so you have even
more options for how
you can do key management
with our partners.
We hope that you find these much
simpler than managing your keys
on-prem, and again, love
to hear any feedback
on that functionality.
So again, how does
this work in practice
for all of these options?
We have a storage object.
That storage object
is split into chunks.
The chunks are encrypted
with data encryption keys.
The data encryption keys are
encrypted with key encryption
keys.
And the key encryption key will
come from a variety of places,
depending on what you're
trying to do, right?
It'll come from default
Google encryption,
using our internal KMS.
Right now you can implement a
similar model using application
layer encryption for Cloud KMS.
Or you can use a
customer-supplied encryption
key, where you provide
us with some bits--
either directly or via partner,
via one of our five partners--
and we'll add a
cryptographic nonce,
and then use that in our system.
So that's, I think, all I was
actually going to talk about.
So I went really fast.
If you go to this
link, there will
be information on
all of the options
that I've talked about
today, additional information
on the white paper I mentioned.
We have a couple of
code labs that you
can do using Cloud KMS,
so there's actually one
if you go to the first
floor, downstairs.
I'll also be standing
outside of the security area,
if you have any questions.
And then will be a
blog post next week,
announcing the partners
and some new functionality
for secret management and
all that kind of stuff.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]